we have 300 million pattern recognizers
in the neocortex by my estimate that
hierarchy we build ourselves and each of
these pattern recognizers capable of
connecting itself to other neocortex is
to build this hierarchy we build that
hierarchy from the moment were born or
before that we're constantly building it
but we run up against this limitation of
300 million we'll be able to extend that
and think in the cloud you know if you
do anything interesting with this do a
search or a language translation or
bring up a map or ask it a question it
doesn't take place in the box goes out
to the cloud we're gonna put these just
really with gateways this is a gateway
to the cloud we're gonna put gateways to
the cloud in our brains and have more
than 300 million just like the cloud can
give you a thousand or a million
computers for a tenth of a second you
need another billion pattern recognizers
you'll be able access that in the cloud
you